Our fan club's finally open!
Oh yeah, we have one of those now!
It's gonna be the best place to get checkies from us!
Oh guys, wanna give people a rundown on what a checkie is?
Sure, a checkie is a Polaroid photo that idols take for
fans.
They're usually decorated and personalized.
Our fan club's gonna have a unique checkie from us every
month.
Yep, you can sign up on Patreon now to get our first set.
What else does the fan club offer?
What a great and totally not planned question, Bickey.
The fan club has a monthly postcard from us and stickers
too.
Depending on your tier, you get different merch items
monthly.
Each month we pick a new artist to draw us and design some
stickers.
Then they get sent to you alongside the checkies.
That's a great lead-in to introducing our artist for this
month.
Are you ready?
It's kids!
She's drawn up a really pretty group pick of us performing
together.
I think that it's the perfect way to kick off our club.
There's worldwide shipping too, so don't worry about where
you are.
Plus, she did one sticker for each of us to really bring out
our individual child.
Oh, they're so cute!
Remember, this postcard will only be available in January.
Our spotlight artists rotate out monthly, so it's only while
they're around.
But don't worry, you can get a digital background version of
the group art for your phone wallpaper or whatever.
That won't go away.
The fan club's the best place to directly support us, so
we're really looking forward to having you be a part of it.
Plus, members of the club will have exclusive pre-sale
access to any group shows we do, roles in the official
dencensor.exe discord the fan club is the best way to
directly support us as a group so if you want to see more
from us we hope to see you there we'll have some exclusive
members only content for club members as well so keep your
eyes here thanks for all your support so far guys we're
making a giant leap into 2026 and we can't wait to show you
what we've got planned bye for now bye